the shooting shocked the tightly-knit
community at Pensacola and raised
questions about the training programs
that allowed hundreds of international
cadets to attend courses at US bases the
FBI interviewed some 500 people in its
investigation in which it found that the
shooter muhammad al sham rami acted
alone and that none of his fellow saudi
officers had any foreknowledge of the
attack but the social media accounts of
21 of the cadets contained what the US
Attorney General called derogatory
material most cases ranging from what is
described as terrorist related content
to child pornography the relevant US
Attorneys offices independently reviewed
each of the 21 cases involving
derogatory information and determined
that none of them would in the normal
course result in federal prosecution
however the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
determined that this material
demonstrated conduct unbecoming an
officer in the Royal Saudi Air Force and
in the Royal Navy and the 21 cadets have
been disenrolled from their training
curriculum in the US military and will
be returned returning to Saudi Arabia
yeah I also released details about the
shooters activities in the days leading
to the attack which included a visit to
the 9/11 memorial in New York City as
well as posting a number of anti US and
anti Israeli comments on his social
media feeds the conclusion that the
killings were an act of terrorism
motivated by a violent ideology Mike
Hanna al Jazeera Washington